since uber invaded our business they
messed up my life it is that a real
bailout because we're not asking for a
penny we want Big Poppa pay attention to
us when and rumour Stein hired pop music
star Nicki Minaj to headline his son
Matt's Bar Mitzvah it was an unusually
conspicuous flaunting of wealth by one
of New York City's leading taxi cab
magnates Newsweek estimates that Minaj
might have been paid as much as half a
million dollars for the gig which
entailed taking a personal photo with
every single prepubescent boy in
attendance and rumor steams vast wealth
derives from a shrewd decision that his
grandpa Leon made 78 years ago in 1937
New York city issued would ultimately
amount to thirteen thousand four hundred
and thirty seven taxi medallions a
special kind of license that conferred
the exclusive right to drive a cab in
the Big Apple and Leon mercy I bought
one for $10 and then he bought several
hundred more to rent out to other
drivers over the next 75 years the price
of those medallions climbed from $10 to
over a million dollars ultimately all
that value that's built up in the
medallions comes out of passengers Josh
barro is a reporter at the New York
Times who covers the taxi industry fares
are higher than they would otherwise be
able to be because you have to limit the
number of people using these taxis
over the years the city tried
periodically to break the medallion
cartel to make life easier on the riding
public but to no avail
and then in May of 2011 a new company
rolled into town welcome to BRR a
reliable ride is always just minutes
away let's get one these are all the
cars in your area and how close they are
for roughly two and a half years after
Ebers arrival the taxi industry kept
thriving in November 2013 medallion
financial the publicly traded company
that's run by and rumor steam saw its
share price hit a 13-year high but as
more and more Oberer cars took to the
streets the stock plummeted ultimately
losing about half of its value the
average number of trips taken in a cab
each day has fallen an average fare box
revenue is fallen the front of this taxi
garage in Brooklyn is jammed with parked
cabs because the company that runs it
can't find enough drivers to hire they'd
all rather go work for uber it really is
remarkable how these monopolies that
couldn't be broken for decades were
broken so quickly but I think it was
because of were moving first makes the
saying we're going to show people how
this can be different and then we'll
have the fight about whether we want
that different person the murse teens
diversified out of the medallion market
long ago so they'll end up rich no
matter what happens but Jean Freedman
the city's largest single medallion
holder with an estimated 900 to his name
is in deep trouble he's been sued by the
Attorney General for ripping off drivers
flagged as a tax delinquent and a
handful of the taxi garages he owns have
filed for bankruptcy protection in April
Friedman arranged a private meeting with
bankers medallion owners and elected
officials to build support for a city
bailout so scream who buy a child for
attention what you're doing is this date
that's correct
Fairchild that's right this time
industries a child know you think that
we are absolute we're all children of
the city we're all children of the city
in the City Council and of City Hall his
idea is that the government should step
in and offer a loan guarantee so
taxpayers would take the hit if
medallion prices were to keep tumbling
it is that a real bailout because we're
not asking for anything for up
yeah the problem is that the city is
guaranteeing a repayment on a medallion
loan at a level exceeding the actual
market price of a taxi medallion then
the city's going to be left on the hook
for millions and millions and
conceivably billions of dollars in lost
value on medallion now what people like
Jean would say is that there's just a
temporary disruption in this market it's
like 2008 a financial crisis but if the
government just steps in and acts as a
guarantor things will go back to normal
that's not what's happening in the taxi
space there's an actual solvency problem
which is that the real value of a taxi
medallion has declined because you
cannot generate as much profit off of a
taxi medallion as you used to be able to
I used to work hard to get my dream come
true in this country sweet land of
liberty yes Allah Khalil is an Egyptian
immigrant who spent years driving
someone else's cab about 90 hours a week
in 1994 he'd finally saved enough to
make a down payment and his very own
medallion which cost a hundred and
seventy eight thousand dollars between
94 and 2013 it was a really good life
since Boober invade our business they
messed up my life lists fares to the
airports they took all the airports and
we used to see a lot of people on the
street and now people are waiting in
front of their houses with the iPhones
looking for the offer to come and they
never hate us anymore
I'm in financial crisis I stopped
payment all of my crackers what if you
lose this house what about my kids was
he gonna live it's really hard selling
his medallion is no longer an option
because there's no liquidity in the
market nobody even knows what a
medallion would sell for at this point
because in the past four months there
hasn't been a single sale just five bank
foreclosures you're gonna strip my
medallion if I don't pay like two months
they take your time while you're
sleeping inside the people I would worry
about are these individual cab operators
who are one medallion
who tied up their life savings the
medallion it's sad and I think that
there are you know there are real people
who got hurt here but again
I would remember that the value in those
medallions was not free value in those
medallions came out of elevated prices
paid by consumers and taxi rides Alec
Aliyah went be in so much trouble
if he hadn't treated his medallion like
a cash register over the years as its
price soared he took vacations bought an
expensive house and a luxury car overall
he borrowed an additional three hundred
thousand dollars against its value IRA
finance in the medallion too many times
I mean like three four types every time
I need money I needed money I go and
pick up like fifty thousand forty
thousand it was a lot of money in the
medina now I have nothing inside this is
an argument for why you shouldn't create
a medallion system not every city
exposes small investors to this business
of making big bets in public policy and
we should try to build our economy not
around the government creating extra
opportunities for people to make those
sorts of unwise investments uber has
been unequivocally good for taxi
customers and is even Khalil
acknowledges it's also been good for
many drivers it's a good opportunity for
immigrants yes yes because they don't
you're gonna find that a new job and
passed and make money fast my nephew is
an Oprah he's been here like five years
and he makes as much as I make now I'm
happy for him but I'm not happy for my
priority
you